don't ever want to be in that good of
shape again
really it's like it's I was so it was so
hard we ate a ton of food during
Baywatch tremendous amounts of food like
he'll eat like twice the amount of
protein I have in a day and a huge thing
of carbs and he'll just have it like in
a one five minute period between a tank
the hardest part was eating you know you
just have to eat a ton a ton of calories
I was eating so much chicken breast
the hardest part about it was actually
chewing it all so I would just put it
into a blender blend it all up and just
drink chicken I didn't eat carbs for
like two months that was kind of gnarly
the last time I had a donut was uh I
think about the time you [__] up in
the Olympics you're coming right out of
your trailer and have to look like that
yeah an Olympic Athlete you're working
with almost no wiggle room right you've
got things like water under your skin
that you're worrying about like making
your six-pack into a four pack [__] like
that that's just like not it's just
stupid